over the past 24 hours we've gotten a
huge reaction to last night's angle
about the horrific murder of
60-year-old bernal trammell in milwaukee
wisconsin
he was gunned down in broad daylight one
week ago tonight
mr trammell had been a fixture in his
river west neighborhood
and a supporter of both blm and lately
for the re-election of donald j trump
the site of a rastafarian poet holding a
re-elect trump sign was unusual to say
the least
and some believe his killing was
politically motivated
while police are still investigating
they saw the man
shown in this photo and they say he's
the prime
murder suspect as of this evening
neither blm
nor a single democrat elected official
in the state of wisconsin
has commented on mr trammell's death
not a peep from milwaukee mayor tom
barrett
nothing from wisconsin governor tony
evers
nothing from attorney general josh call
not any of the democrat congressmen
none have expressed their condolences or
outrage about the possible political
slang
of a peaceful law-abiding
african-american man
this ear splitting silence follows a
disturbing pattern of democrat
disinterest in the larger
african-american community as well
now since the coronavirus lockdowns and
racial justice protests began
killings of black men women and even
children have skyrocketed
but not at the hands of bad cops
overwhelmingly these murders have been
committed
by other african-american men now of
course al
sharpton and blm activists don't show up
to march against this carnage
no calls for the removal of mayors and
governors who refuse to tackle violent
crime
and do so head-on no celebrities doing
instagram live concerts in memory of the
victims
why is that because there's no political
benefit in it that's why now a similar
scenario is playing out in the debate
over reopening schools this fall
teachers unions joined at the hip with
democrats have refused to return to
their jobs
today washington d.c public schools
joined a slew
of other school districts in announcing
there would be zero
in-person learning for kids it's all
going to be online
now pretty much every pediatric
specialist i've seen believes
this 100 distance learning approach is a
total disaster it's terrible for all
children
and all parents but especially for
at-risk kids
from single-parent families we know that
children from low-income families in
particular
who are being homeschooled they're not
getting an adequate education
because their parents are working
particularly that younger age group k-8
distance learning just does not work
many low-income
families their children do not have
access to the internet
they don't have support for doing remote
learning
but how could democrats endorse keeping
kids at home full time
when the virus poses a minuscule threat
to young americans
after all day care centers for essential
workers never shut down
and grocery store employees they show up
every day to work as do bus drivers and
nurses
so why do educators get a special
stay-at-home pass
especially while they claim to care so
much about the welfare of the children
president and his administration are
messing with the health of our children
moms and dads are worried i'm worried as
a grandparent about whether or not my
grandkids are going to be able to go
back to school
safely you know and these as i've said
before these aren't somebody else's kids
they're all our kids
now of course shutting everything down
is a democrats only real answer to the
coronavirus
from california to michigan you see a
pre-election momentum beginning to build
to either pause
or reverse reopenings today maryland's
liberal republican governor larry hogan
cited cases
in other states to justify halting
his own state's reopening we will remain
paused at this point
and not move into stage three openings
until it is safe prudent and thoroughly
backed
by the data looking at these other
states they've been doing pretty well
and
shot up and we don't want to be one of
them
it's unbelievable montgomery county
maryland's numbers are actually
really encouraging of course these
decisions are driven not by what's good
for the general welfare
but by politics lockdowns plus
trillions in welfare spending until
apparently there's zero virus in america
that's realistic
now remember the initial justification
for stay-at-home orders
was the need to preserve the hospital
system you could kind of understand that
but now they're using these lockdowns or
pauses
to preserve biden's chances of beating
trump
it's truly disgusting and whom do these
lockdowns and school closures end up
hurting the most
well rich families they hire tutors and
they take up new hobbies at home
it's the poor families who'll struggle
as they try to hold down
jobs and oversee kids zoom classes and
all the homework
the divide between the haves and the
have-nots
will only widen but one gets a sense
that the virus fear-mongering is
beginning to wear
thin and that more families see the need
to move on to preserve what we have
while still protecting the most
vulnerable even the new york times seems
to think that the unions have
maybe overstepped in risk alienating
millions of voters reporting that
teachers in many districts are fighting
for longer school closures
stronger safety requirements and limits
on what they're required to do in
virtual classrooms
while flooding social media and state
capitals with their concerns
and threatening to walk off their jobs
if their key demands are not met
demands now they can sit at home
and their t-shirt and shorts get the
same pay
and they're issuing demands the miami
teachers union is pushing to limit
online learning
limit online learning yeah why well
according to the times they've cited
anxiety about
how they and their homes would look on
camera
touring live teaching so they're not
going to go to the classroom
and they don't want to teach online
that's perfect with their local union
leader saying that if a teacher does not
feel comfortable and the teacher is not
secure in the modality
they're not going to flourish and give
the best of themselves
modality what about the comfort of
students will they be able to flourish
cooped up in their homes sharing a
computer screen with a brother or sister
if they even have one
and do this for months on end the left
doesn't care
if it was really about safety why are
teachers unions fighting reopening plans
even in states where the virus is under
control
in hawaii for example which has one of
the lowest coveted rates in the country
teachers are resisting fully reopening
including on the small island of lanai
which had zero zero confirmed cases
now thankfully president trump wants the
kids back in school and he has a
solution for unions
and school districts that do not put
kids first
say if a school doesn't want to open or
if a governor doesn't want to open maybe
for political reason or maybe not
but there is some of that going on the
money should go to the parents
so they can send their children to the
school of their choice
bingo school choice go to a school
that's actually teaching
the nea and the aft are powerful forces
but if they only remain so i think they
only will remain so if americans
continue to believe that public
education
is still worthwhile by refusing to teach
by politicizing curricula by
jeopardizing our children's mental
and physical well-being they're showing
us
how non-essential they're becoming and
that's the angle